[Music]
to the people of Syria and Iraq and
France and Germany and Mexico and Canada
and the world
permit me to apologize on behalf of the
citizens of the United States of America
for the unforgivable actions of the man
who has assumed power here I speak for
those of us who unlike Trump
unlike the sycophants who surround him
unlike the hate filled Souls and the
conscience optional bigots who applaud
him unlike the Russian puppeteers who
may be manipulating him I speak for
those of us who have not forgotten and
will not forget that we are the
descendants of the immigrants often the
refugees we are the modern equivalents
of those whom this pig Trump has just
banished and degraded and in many cases
likely literally sentenced to death our
greatness and more importantly our
goodness has since the cliche of the
arrival at Plymouth Rock stemmed
entirely from people who came here from
elsewhere the only true natives of this
continent have been the victims of
persecution and marginalization and
genocide if this gargoyle Trump really
believed in America first he would lead
the deportation of those who brutally
stole these lands from their rightful
inhabitants indeed if there is anything
this country can offer as mitigating
evidence against our original sin it is
that the land our forefathers invaded
became a place of freedom a destination
for those who literally had no other
place to turn we became great and
greater and greatest because to these
shores came a world of brave men and
women who could not be certain it would
be better here but who knew it could not
be worse than where they were they
gained a sanctuary and we gained their
courage and their dedication and their
hard work and their belief that if life
would not be better for them it would be
better for their children in us in this
place they saw the light of the world
and because of them we became that light
and now Trump has extinguished it
he has extinguished the light of the
world because it was necessary because
it was protective because it will almost
certainly indeed prove the opposite but
because many of those who support him
cried out for scapegoats and for people
to
hate because they believe a different
religion and for people to blame because
they looked different and in their hate
he without conscience soul morality he
capable proudly mocking the tears of
those stricken by the human cost of his
cruelty over the weekend saw only how to
gain more power he has extinguished the
light of the world
not because he wanted to prevent
terrorism nor reduce the flow of
would-be terrorists but because the
political currency of 21st century
America is making the gullible afraid of
convincing them that a foreigner lurks
around every corner when the greatest
risk of death to Americans is other
Americans who have guns period the seven
countries to whose residence visas will
not be issued are Iraq Iran Libya
Somalia Sudan Syria and Yemen from data
research by the libertarian think-tank
the Cato Institute the number of
Americans killed in terrorism on
American soil by people from those
countries from 1975 through 2016 was
none the countries of the Middle East
against which Trump did not act include
the home nations of all the 9/11
hijackers and the San Bernardino
attackers Pakistan and the United States
and most cynically of all those
countries in which Trump has business
dealings none of Donald Trump's
grandparents were born in this country
virtually none of his supporters who
style themselves as real Americans are
not the descendants of immigrants or
refugees the nation they know the things
here that have given them life has been
built entirely by the children and
grandchildren of exactly the kind of
people whose banishment and punishment
they now cheer my great great
grandfather was a blacksmith and he came
here from Hamburg in Germany and he
became a naturalized American citizen in
1854 Donald Trump's grandfather was a
scared teenager and he came here from
bremen in germany 60 miles from Hamburg
in 1885 Trump's grandfather was born
with the name Friedrich and once here he
changed it to Frederick my
great-great-grandfather was born with
the name Friedrich and once here changed
it to Frederick 125 years after
Frederick Olbermann got here
I became the first of his direct
descendants to be able to afford to go
to and graduate from college and this is
with me daily and I consider myself the
child of immigrants and my eyes well
with prideful tears that transcend time
when I think of his sacrifices and his
efforts and the abuse that he bore and
the fact that I got to enjoy the fruits
of his struggle 132 years after
Frederick Trump got here
his grandson betrayed him Friday he took
a first step towards changing the law in
such a way that his own grandfather
would not have been certain to get a
Visa Waiver to get into this country and
even if Frederick Trump had gotten here
and gotten a green card he still might
not have been safe for his own grandson
and his chief of staff the son of a
woman who grew up in Sudan initially
they went after the green card holders
they locked out legal residents of this
country in what may very well be
interpreted as the early
passive-aggressive stage of a kind of
ethnic cleansing and this Trump also
betrayed every other immigrant and every
other refugee and every other man or
woman the world over who looked to us
then or who have looked to us now and
who believed we were who we said we were
I'm sorry
not like the brazen giant of Greek fame
with conquering limbs astride from land
to land here at our sea-washed sunset
gates shall stand a mighty woman with a
torch whose flame is the imprisoned
lightning at her name mother of exiles
from her beacon hand glows worldwide
welcomed her mild eyes command that air
bridge Harbor the Twin Cities frame keep
ancient lands your storied pomp cry she
with silent lips give me your tired your
poor your huddled masses yearning to
breathe free the wretched refuse of your
teeming Shore send these the homeless
tempest-tossed to me I lift my lamp
beside the Golden Door
Donald Trump has branded himself a
traitor to everything this country has
ever stood for we have already acted
against him in the streets and
kourt's we will remove him we will
welcome you again we will even again let
you think that you are getting more from
us even though history proves in
generation after generation with
nationality after nationality that it is
us who are getting everything from you
and until that day we the citizens of
the United States beg your forgiveness